Now I hope you actually spend some time trying
to justify your answer. I've come up with four different
levels of poor to okay, to better, to best.
Answers here that you can evaluate yourself with. I want
you to read each one, and compare it to
the answer you put. See how it measures up to
your explanation. Then I want you to tick the
box that represents where you think your answer best fits.
You could be right on par with one of my answers or in between them.
Go ahead and evaluate yourself! I want to know how you think you did. If you
have any questions or if you want to
see what other people are thinking. You should
definitely check out the forums right now because
I imagine there is some commentary on this.